ustedes han denunciado que los offshore
o los paraísos fiscales funcionan sin
control como operan y por qué son
problemáticos
buenas noches
lo queremos transparencia internacional
viene señalando desde hace ya varios
años es que se necesita utilizar
herramientas mucho más agresivas para
controlar este tipo de
mecanismos de ocultamiento de la riqueza
en muchos casos con fines ilícitos o
esconder dinero de corrupción es contra
dinero del tráfico de armas de tráfico
de drogas evadir impuestos en fin estos
mecanismos más agresivos particularmente
pasan por un shock de transparencia
sobre el conocimiento de quiénes son los
beneficiarios finales los últimos
beneficiarios las personas de carne y
hueso se benefician de estas capas de
empresas bajo las cuales se ocultan
estas personas
usted no habla de herramientas agresivas
y nos menciona brevemente en qué
consisten pero puede profundizar por
favor qué reformas necesitaríamos y
dónde estamos en este momento
si miro a partir del año 2015 2016 se
han empezado a introducir
en los sistemas financieros
internacional nacionales e
internacionales las obligaciones de que
las empresas las compañías
declaren quién es la persona natural el
individuo como digo de carne y hueso que
se beneficia en última instancia de sus
operaciones de esta compañía
esto se ha traducido en que varios
sistemas los países han adoptado los
registros de beneficiarios finales que
así se llaman
en el perú en colombia en panamá en eeuu
en que han ido dando estos registros en
los últimos años entre el 2018 y 2020
cuál es el problema el problema es que
estos registros no son públicos es decir
están hechos para que sean controlados
internamente por los estados lo cual
está bien no por es un paso muy
importante pero
queda la imposibilidad de acceder a ver
desde la ciudadanía del periodismo desde
organizaciones hernán que está
gestionando bien cómo están funcionando
como por qué es por tipo que sean
público samuel y brevemente usted nos
habla de las declaraciones de los
individuos la falta de declaraciones
como los políticos y los famosos abusan
de esta opacidad
este mecanismo ha funcionado por años y
ha sido una industria muy lucrativa
y probé es muy eficiente en proveer
servicios que permiten a mucha gente
ocultar su riqueza de una riqueza
legalmente obtenida legalmente obtenida
no esté aquí funcionan
por igual
dándoles servicios que tratadas a
corruptos como a esta gente porque ha
trabajado duro pero que quiere ocultar
el dinero por distintas razones